♪ ♪
>> WE SHOULD HAVE NATIONAL
VOTING AND THAT MEANS GET RID OF
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
>> I THINK I'M OPEN TO THE
DISCUSSION.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
POPULAR VOTE HAS BEEN DIMINISHED
IN TERMS OF MAKING THE FINAL
DECISION ABOUT WHO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IS AND WE
NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT.
>> WOULD YOU SUPPORT GETTING RID
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> I'VE BEEN FOR LOWERING THE
VOTING AGE TO 16.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CAPTURE KIDS
WHEN THEY ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN ALL OF
THIS.
>> WHAT IF THERE WERE FIVE
JUSTICES ELECTED BY DEMOCRATS
AND FIVE JUSTICES SELECTED BY
REPUBLICANS ON THOSE TEN THEN
PICKED FIVE MORE JUSTICES
INDEPENDENT OF THOSE WHO CHOSE
THE FIRST TEN.
>> Sean: JUST A SMALL GLIMPSE
OF HOW RADICAL, OUT OF TOUCH
THESE NEW CROP OF 2020 DEMOCRATS
HAVE BECOME.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THAT AND MUCH MORE IS THE GREAT
ONE, HE'S THE HOST OF "LIFE,
LIBERTY & LEVIN," NUMBER ONE
SHOW, 10:00 P.M. ON SUNDAYS
RIGHT HERE ON FOX.
AND LEVIN TV.
MARK, YOU LOOK AT OUR FRAMERS,
YOU GO BACK TO 1787 AND THIS IS
YOUR WHEELHOUSE.
16-YEAR-OLDS DEVOTE.
THEY WANT TO STACK THE
SUPREME COURT WITH ACTIVIST
JUSTICES AND LET'S GET RID OF
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE SO
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY AND
ILLINOIS AND CALIFORNIA WILL
ELECT EVERY PRESIDENT GOING
FORWARD.
DYING TO GET YOUR REACTION ON
THAT ON THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, THIS IS ONE
OF THE REASONS I OPPOSE
LEGALIZING POT BECAUSE HONESTLY
WE HAVE A PROBLEM ON
CAPITOL HILL.
LOOK, THE GREATEST THREAT TO OUR
CONSTITUTION AND ECONOMIC SYSTEM
ISN'T ANY FOREIGN POWER.
IT'S THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IT'S THE LEFT WITHIN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY BECAUSE THEY BEAT
USE OUR LIBERTY AND OUR
CONSTITUTION, DESTROY OUR
LIBERTY AND OUR CONSTITUTION AND
THEY ARE VERY GOOD AT IT.
YOU NAME SOME OF THEM.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN?
WHY DO WE HAVE AN ELECTORAL
COLLEGE?
WE HAVE AN ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
WHY DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN THIS
TO PEOPLE WHO WANT TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
BECAUSE THERE WERE STATES WHICH
HAD SMALLER POPULATIONS THAT
WERE NOT GOING TO JOIN THE UNION
IF THE MOST POPULOUS STATES WERE
GOING TO CONTROL THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE AN ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
KEEPS PIECE OF THIS NATION.
WE HAVE A FARM BELT LESS
POPULATED THAN URBAN AREAS.
WE HAVE AN ENERGY SECTOR LESS
WE DON'T WANT TO BE RULED BY
NEW YORK CITY, LOS ANGELES, AND
CHICAGO.
WE SHOULD ALL HAVE A ROLE IN
THIS.
WE ARE A REPUBLIC.
WE ARE NOT A DEMOCRACY.
WE ARE NOT A MOB-AUTOCRACY AND
WHAT YOU SEE HERE ARE NOT PEOPLE
RUNNING RUNNING UNDER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY ARE
RUNNING IN THE MOB PARTY.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IF THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, YOU HAVE TO
AMEND THE CONSTITUTION.
THE ONLY NEED 13 STATES TO SAY
NO.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS 13 STATES
THAT WILL SAY NO?
I THINK THERE'S 20 STATES THAT
WILL SAY NO.
SO THEY ARE ABSOLUTE ILLITERATES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY WANT TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE TRIED THIS.
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT TRIED IT.
UNO STOPPED HIM?
HIS OWN VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY WANT TO PACK THE
SUPREME COURT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO FIX THE OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS
AND THEY WANT TO FIX THE OUTCOME
OF COURT DECISIONS.
THIS IS VERY GOOD BANANA
REPUBLIC OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY WANT TO ALLOW ILLEGAL
ALIENS TO VOTE.
WHY WAIT FOR THEM TO COME
1,000 MILES INTO THE
UNITED STATES?
WHY DON'T WE SENT ABSENTEE
BALANCE IS 7 BILLION PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD AND SAY YOU DON'T
NEED TO STRUGGLE TO GET TO THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU CAN JUST VOTE IN OUR
ELECTIONS.
THEY WANT TO LOWER THE VOTING
AGE TO 16.
WHY NOT LOWERED TO 12?
OR 14 OR 15?
HOW STUPID IS THAT?
THEY RAISED THE AGE FOR
CIGARETTES TO 21.
BUT IT 16 YOU'RE GOING TO HELP
PICK OUR PRESIDENT?
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
BECAUSE THEY INDOCTRINATE ALL
THESE KIDS IN HIGH SCHOOL AND SO
FORTH AND THEY KNOW HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO VOTE, DEMOCRAT.
EVERY DECISION THEY MAKE ARE
EVERYTHING THEY ESPOUSE IS ABOUT
POWER, CONTROLLING POWER.
DO YOU THINK IF WE HAD A MILLION
ILLEGAL GOVERNMENTS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND 75% OF
THEM ONE BECOME UNITED STATES
CITIZENS WHO VOTE REPUBLICAN?
DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD WANT TO
SECURE THE SOUTHERN BORDER?
YOU BET THEY WOULD.
THEY WOULD HAVE SNIPER TOWERS
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THEY DON'T REPUBLICANS COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
NOW WE HAVE A KNUCKLEHEAD
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT HE SAYS WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY START TO
CONFISCATE WEAPONS.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT, THEY CALL
IT VOTER REFORM.
THEY WANT TO TAKE AWAY FREE
SPEECH.
NOW WHERE ONLY THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS INTO THE SELECTION AND THE
KOOKS ARE IN FULL DISPLAY.
WHAT ABOUT OUR ECONOMY?
NATIONALIZE ENERGY.
NATIONALIZE ENERGY?
WE ARE FINALLY ENERGY
INDEPENDENT OR THEY WANT TO
DESTROY.
NATIONALIZE HEALTH CARE.
SINGLE-PAYER.
70 TO 90% MARGINAL TAX RATE.
A VAT TAX, FREE COLLEGE, A
GUARANTEED MINIMUM INCOME FROM
BIRTH, GUARANTEED FEDERAL JOBS,
THREE MONTHS OF TAXPAYER FINANCE
FAMILY LEAVE, EXPAND
SOCIAL SECURITY WHILE THE
TRUSTEE SAY IT'S BANKRUPT IN
2034.
THAT'S THE GENIUS BERNIE SANDERS
BY THE WAY.
ELIMINATE EXISTING BORDER
FENCES.
THAT'S BETO O'ROURKE RIGHT
THERE.
ELIMINATE I.C.E.
REINSTATE THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
WHILE WE ARE IT, IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, INDICT THE PRESIDENT,
INDICT THE PRESIDENT'S CHILDREN
AND LET'S GO AHEAD AND IMPEACH
ASSOCIATE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH.
THAT IS QUITE A POLICY PLANNED
THAT THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE OWNED
WHERE ONLY THREE OR FOUR WEEKS
INTO THIS.
>> Sean: MARK, YOU FORGET ONE
THING.
I NEVER LIKE TO CORRECT YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE ALWAYS RIGHT.
DURING BIRTH AND AFTER BIRTH
ABORTION.
DELIVER THE BABY, MAKE SURE THE
BABY IS COMFORTABLE, AND LET THE
MOTHER DECIDE.
WOW.
DID YOU EVER THINK IT ALL YOUR
YEARS YOU WOULD HEAR THIS, EVEN
ALL THESE THINGS HE MENTIONED
EVER BEING SERIOUSLY DISCUSSED?
LIKE 100 DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
ABORTING IT.
AND 2020 CANDIDATES.
>> LISTEN TO HOW CRAZY THESE
PEOPLE ARE.
WERE GOING TO ELIMINATE STRAWS
TO SAVE THE WHALES BUT
INFANTICIDE OF HUMAN BEINGS IS A
RIGHT, CHOICE BETWEEN A MOTHER
AND A DOCTOR.
NO, IT'S NOT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING
BEFORE WE GO, TO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A STATESMAN.
WHAT YOU'VE DONE IN ISRAEL WILL
BE REMEMBERED FOR 1,000 YEARS.
THE GOLAN HEIGHTS, MOVING THE
EMBASSY FROM TEL AVIV TO
JERUSALEM, TAKING ON THE
TERRORISTS IN HAMAS AND THE
PALESTINIAN LIBERATION
ORGANIZATION OFFICE THAT YOU
CLOSE IN THE PLA.
SHREDDING THE IRAN DEAL WHICH
WAS A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL AS OUR
ALLIES, THE GULF ARAB STATES AND
THE ISRAELIS TOO.
HONESTLY WE HAVE FOUR DEMOCRATS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, ELIZABETH
WARREN, JULIAN CASTRO,
BERNIE SANDERS, KAMALA HARRIS,
NONE OF THEM WILL SPEAK AT AIPAC
WHICH IS A MODERATE LEFT OF
CENTER ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS ISRAEL.
THAT'S HOW HARD-CORE THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME
ANTI-ISRAEL.
WHEN THEY HAVE AND ANTI-SEMITE
AMONG THEM, THEY CAN'T EVEN PASS
A RESOLUTION SPECIFICALLY
CONDEMN THE ANTI-SEMITE BY NAME.
AND YET THE NUMBER THREE
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES YET AGAIN AND
THAT PARTY COMPARE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO
ADOLF HITLER.
THIS IS A SICK PARTY.
THESE ARE SICK PEOPLE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE IS NO OTHER EXPLANATION
FOR THIS.
>> Sean: MARK CLEMENT, WE HAVE
MISSED YOU FOR THREE MONTHS.
PLEASE COME BACK A LITTLE MORE
REGULARLY.
AMAZING COMMENTARY TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.